Hey, c’est quoi ça ?
Attend, mais c’est une météorite !
Bah oui c’est une météorite ! Ça se voit que c’est une météorite.
Ça foutait quoi dans mon lit ?
Quoi ? Mais nan mais c’est le chien.
Tu sais, il prend toujours des trucs comme ça, il va les mettre à des endroits.
Quel galopin.
C’est une météorite !
Oui ! C’est fou hein.
Y’a un seul truc que j’aime autant que les feuilles de vigne et les chansons de Bernard Minet en vitesse x2,
c’est les météorites.
Outre leur ressemblance frappante avec des petits cacas de l’espace,
elles sont surtout des témoins de l’Histoire avec un grand H.
L’une d’elles était même aux premières loges quand les dinosaures non aviaires sont mourus...
vu qu’elle les a un peu zigouillés.
Vous vous rappelez de cette époque ?
Enfin, vous peut-être pas, mais votre maman sans doute.
C’était il y a 66 millions d’années.
C’est la crise, la vraie.
Pas celle qui ébranle les traders et les classes moyennes non, non,
celle qui terrasse 75 % des espèces sur Terre.
Et on sait même pas si elles ont eu le temps de sécuriser leurs placements avant de passer l’arme à gauche,
c’est peut-être ça le plus triste.
Le scénario catastrophe, le voici.
Rodriguez est une fat météorite qui pèse au moins 1000 milliards de tonnes
et mesure 11 à 80 km de diamètre.
Ce n’est pas rien puisque c’est la distance entre Fougères et Paimpont.
Rodriguez donc, impacte la Terre dans le Golfe du Mexique.
Sans avoir le temps de crier “Timber !”, elle creuse un cratère de plus de 20 km de profondeur, le cratère de Chicxulub.
Elle déclenche un tsunami qui se propage dans tous les océans du globe,
projette dans l’atmosphère des nuages de poussières et une pluie de cailloux, comme un fléau biblique.
Et là, pour le vivant, ça sent le sapin.
Les chercheurs ont même retrouvé dans les branchies de poissons fossiles des petites billes de verre
qu’ils ont respiré avant de mourir !
Ces billes, c’est ce qu’on appelle des micro-tectites.
Ce sont des éclats de roches terrestres qui sont créés par l’impact de la météorite.
Sous le choc, les éclats fondent instantanément et sont propulsés dans l’air.
Ils refroidissent en plein vol et sans même avoir le temps de bien arranger leurs atomes,
du coup ça donne des petites gouttes de verre.
En fait, les derniers instants des dinosaures ressemblaient probablement à ça.
Imaginez un ciel constellé de minuscules gouttes de verre incandescentes
comme autant d’étoiles filantes qui vont se fourrer directement dans leurs naseaux et les cramer de l’intérieur
et de l’extérieur aussi,
puisque la température ambiante a avoisiné très vite celle d’un four à pizza.
Heureusement pour nous, des météorites aussi grosses que l’ego de Monté, ça ne court pas les rues.
Mange tes morts Valentine.
On estime qu’en moyenne, y’en a une tous les 100 millions d’années.
En moyenne hein, ça veut pas dire qu’on va s’en emplafonner une dans 40 millions d’années, il peut y en avoir deux d’un coup
puis plus rien pendant un bail.
C’est la joie des statistiques.
Cela dit, heureusement que c’est rare,
parce qu’aujourd’hui on n’a toujours pas de moyen pour dévier un astéroïde un peu trop affectueux.
Mais du coup, les astéroïdes et les météorites,
c’est pas pareil ?
Alors, dans l’espace c’est un astéroïde,
quand ça travers l’atmosphère c’est un météore,
- Et sur Terre...
- Oui, oui, on sait, sur Terre, une météorite.
N’empêche vous aimez bien vous prendre la tête.
Vous n'auriez pu appeler ça, je sais pas… “un caillou spatial”.
Et d’ailleurs, un ou une astéroïde ?
Hein ?
Bande de branquignols…
Attend mais, ce mansplaining de l’espace !
Mais qu’est-ce que tu racontes, pas du tout, le mansplaining, c’est pas du tout ça, c’est quand tu...
Mais revenons-en à nos météorites.
Celles qui dominent le paysage, ce sont des poussières, des grains de moins de 2 mm de diamètre
qui nous font des jolies petites étoiles filantes quand elles entrent dans l’atmosphère
et qui nous permettent de faire des voeux comme être heureux ou voir une étoile filante.
On estime que plus de 99% des cailloux célestes disparaissent complètement en traversant notre atmosphère,
où les frottements avec l’air les grillent joyeusement.
Mais il nous parvient quand-même 5.000 tonnes de poussières extraterrestres au sol chaque année,
et également 5.000 météorites assez balèzes, de la taille d’un ballon de handball.
Et si en plus on a la chance de les voir tomber du ciel, rebel aux louanges,
Ça c’est la référence pour les plus de 60 ans. Coucou Maman.
c’est vraiment un moment magique.
Enfin, sauf si elle vous tombe dessus.
D'ailleurs, on n’y a pas toujours cru à ces météorites..
Aujourd’hui ça nous paraît évident.
Mais jusqu’au 19e siècle, les savants occidentaux regardaient les pécores et leur disaient :
“Ouaiiiiis, des pierres qui tombent du ciel.
Et puis quoi encore, des pluies de biquettes ?
Un magazine féminin sans promotion des pseudosciences ?
On me la fait pas, à moi.
Les extraterrestres là, ça a déjà pas marché dans Indiana Jones, ça marchera pas mieux pour vous.
Non, moi je dis, ça doit être
un bon gros coup de vent qui les aura soulevées,
ou alors c’est juste des pierres volcaniques ou des pierres de foudre.”
Nan mais ils se sont crus au centre commercial de céladopole avec Pikachu ou quoi…
Je parle des fulgurites, c’est quand la foudre tombe sur une roche et qu’elle la fait fondre.
Oui bah, comme mon cerveau quand j’vous écoute.
Pour vous dire à quel point on n’y croyait pas,
en 1492, une énorme météorite tombe en Alsace, à Ensess… Ainess…
Enseisheim.
Merci.
Les villageois en prélèvent des bouts et s’en font des talismans,
puis la météorite est récupérée et placée dans l’église.
On lui prête même un présage comme quoi elle aurait prophétisé qui gagnerait une bataille de l’époque.
C’est un peu comme un Paul le Poulpe de l’espace.
Et puis quelques érudits y mettent leur nez.
Paracelse, philosophe et médecin, a conclu que la pierre était
"identique à la matière terrestre"
et lui de "renvoyer les habitants d’Ensisheim à leurs superstitions et à leur église".
Un peu moins de deux siècles plus tard,
Goethe, de passage dans le coin, a lui aussi examiné le caillou céleste
et s’est moqué de "la crédulité des humains
qui imaginaient voir tomber des pierres dans leurs champs".
Il aura donc fallu attendre 1794 pour que le physicien allemand Ernst Chladni
(comme ça se prononce)
propose pour la première fois que les pierres tombées du ciel existent bel et bien,
qu’elles ont une origine extraterrestre et qu’elles peuvent nous apprendre deux-trois petits trucs sur les autres mondes.
C’était une véritable rupture épistémologique, à l’époque.
Sa thèse n’a pas eu un succès fou tout de suite.
Mais c’est au début des années 1800,
après avoir enquêté méthodiquement autour de la chute d’une météorite en Normandie,
que la communauté scientifique a dit aux paysans :
“En fait, vous aviez raison, autant pour nous.
Aller, sans rancune !”
Mais tout le monde ne croyait pas aux météorites.
Certains y croyaient, quoi.
Comme Anaxagore de Clazomènes.
Cet Antique philosophe grec présocratique (et ce n’est pas une insulte)
pensait que les météorites étaient des pierres détachées du Soleil.
Alors que tout le monde considérait que les astres étaient des dieux,
lui pensait que c’était des pierres incandescentes.
Il disait même que celle du Soleil était plus grande que le Péloponnèse.
C’est ce qu’on appelle avoir du flair.
Bref, trêve de pierres incandescentes.
Non seulement ces cailloux de l’espace ont pu assister à nos chamailleries scientifiques,
mais en plus ils ont contribué au développement de nos civilisations.
Et pour ça, je vous emmène dans un tombeau.
Ce tombeau ne sera pas votre tombeau, car c’est celui de Toutankhamon.
En 1926, on a découvert dans le cercueil du pharaon une dague bien particulière
puisqu’on apprendra 90 ans plus tard
que sa lame a été forgée dans un métal extraterrestre,
issu d’une météorite.
Est-ce qu’il faut y voir un symbole particulier pour autant ? Pas sûr.
A l’époque, les météorites, c’étaient surtout pratiquement
Un minerai extrêmement rare et donc très précieux,
exploité dès la Préhistoire.
On pense même que les tout premiers objets en fer
étaient fabriqués à partir de métal météoritique.
Et ce minerai a été utilisé depuis au Tibet, en Chine, en Syrie, en Mésopotamie
et même, de façon beaucoup plus contemporaine,
par les Inuits au nord du Groënland.
Ils n’avaient pas assez de bois pour inventer la métallurgie.
Du coup ils ont fabriqué leurs outils et leurs harpons
en utilisant des fragments de la météorite de Cap York,
qui serait tombée il y a plusieurs milliers d’années dans la région d'Anna… Avaata…
Avannaata.
Donc on peut presque dire que l’âge du fer des Inuits est d’origine extraterrestre.
Enfin ça, c’était jusqu’en 1894,
jusqu’à ce que l’explorateur américain Robert Peary se fasse rencarder sur l’endroit où étaient ces météorites.
Le mec a rien trouvé de mieux que de rafler les fragments et de ramener son butin aux Etats-Unis.
Il les a revendus au Muséum d’Histoire naturelle de New-York, où ils sont encore visibles aujourd’hui.
On est sûr que c’est une météorite du coup ?
Ah bah totalement que c’est une météorite, je l’ai vue tomber !
Ah ça, c’est un bon indice, en général.
Sinon,certains types de météorites sont assez denses parce qu’elles sont riches en métal.
Ensuite, c’est souvent foncé, lisse et doux au toucher comme la barbe d’Un Créatif.
Et ça, c’est ce qu’on appelle sa croûte de fusion.
Elle se crée quand la pierre s’échauffe en traversant l’atmosphère.
Ensuite, si on avait de quoi l’ouvrir, on pourrait regarder si y’a des grumeaux à l’intérieur.
C'est pas le cas pour toutes, mais la plupart en ont.
En fait, c’est des gouttes de magma qui ont cristallisé en apesanteur dans l'espace.
On les appelle des chondres.
Du coup, on en fait quoi de la météorite. On la fout dans un musée ou...
FLORENCE ?
Tu fais quoi avec un oeuf de Yoni toi ?
Un quoi ?
Nan nan, mais c’est une météorite !
Et pourquoi y a une ficelle au bout alors ?
Ah non mais c’est moi ça, j’ai voulu en faire un...
collier.
Du coup, on voulait te demander, cette météorite, on la file à un musée ou on peut la garder ?
Bah, c’est un peu compliqué parce qu’en France, tu n’as pas vraiment de loi
qui va protéger la météorite.
Tu as des décisions de justice qui datent du XIXe siècle à peu près.
Des fois, il disait : “c’est le propriété de la personne qui avait le terrain”.
Des fois, c’est la propriété de la personne qui la découverte.
Mais en fait, tu n’as aucune mention, à aucun moment de l’aspect scientifique qu’il peut y avoir.
Et même en 2014, tu avais une décision de justice qui en parlait
et c’était revenu à la personne qui avait découvert la météorite.
Mais on ne sait pas du tout ce qu’il en faisait ensuite. S’il le donnait à un musée ou quoi.
Donc, en 2014, ne pas tenir compte de l’aspect scientifique que peut avoir une météorite, on n’est un peu à la bourre quand même.
Mais ce n’est pas le cas partout, parce que tu as des pays qui vont t’obliger à la remettre à l’État…
donc à un musée. Là, c’est le cas de l’Inde.
T’as des pays qui vont prévoir une compensation financière en échange,
parce que ça peut représenter beaucoup d’argent. Danemark, Suisse et tout ça.
Et d’autres pays qui vont dire : “c’est la propriété de la personne qui l’a découverte”.
C’est le cas du Royaume-Uni, de la Russie, des États-Unis par exemple.
Les États-Unis, ça me fait penser, c’est la même chose pour les fossiles.
Si tu retrouves un fossile de dinosaure dans ton jardin aux États-Unis, tu peux le garder en fait.
Tu sais que dans les années 60-70, on a fait des traités par rapport à l’espace, à la Lune et tout ça.
On a mis un principe de non-appropriation.
C’est un peu le patrimoine commun de l’Humanité si tu veux.
Sauf qu’il y a une exception pour les météorites précisément.
Je vais te lire le truc. Ça dit :
“ne s’applique pas aux matières extra-terrestres qui atteignent la surface de la Terre par des moyens naturels”.
Tu sais que je me suis appuyée sur un rapport du projet Vigie-Ciel
qui forme des gens pour qu’ils puissent reconnaître les météorites,
et les ramener à des musées sans les abîmer ou ce genre de chose.
Ca fait partie des programmes de sciences participatives du Museum d’Histoires Naturelles ça.
Ouais, carrément. C’est super intéressant, ils ont même fait une charte des cueilleurs de météorites.
Je trouve ça trop mignon.
Si on demande à notre météorite : “Elle est où ta maman ?”.
La réponse sera probablement entre Mars et Jupiter, dans la ceinture d’astéroïdes principale.
Là-bas, les cailloux de l’espace aiment bien se collisionner pour le fun, comme des vrais bonhommes,
et ce faisant, ils se font des petits peelings réciproques.
On a donc des petites miettes d’astéroïdes, leurs peaux mortes, qui volettent joyeusement dans l’espace
et qui saupoudrent parfois les autres corps du système solaire, comme des pellicules divines.
Je crois que je vais m’arrêter là avec cette métaphore.
Bref, l‘immense majorité de nos météorites proviennent d’astéroïdes.
Pour les autres, ça peut être des bouts de Mars ou de la Lune arrachés lors d’un impact avec un gros astéroïde, qui nous arrivent directement par colis postal.
Et même s’ils ne représentent que moins d’1 % de toutes les météorites qu’on trouve sur Terre,
ces morceaux de Lune ou de Mars sont hyper utiles aux scientifiques
parce qu’ils leur permettent d’étudier le sol de ces corps sans même avoir à y poser le pied.
Ce qui est rigolo, c’est qu’en 2019, on a trouvé une météorite terrienne sur la Lune
dans un échantillon lunaire rapporté par les missions Apollo.
C'était un petit éclat de granite incorporé dans une brèche lunaire.
Donc tout ça pour dire que ça marche dans les deux sens.
Mais c’est pas tout.
On disait à l’instant que les météorites avaient été témoins de notre Histoire, ça, ok,
mais c’est surtout de vraies capsules temporelles qui nous aident à reconstituer le scénario de la formation du système solaire.
Et pour ça, il faut creuser un peu leur chimie. Parce que non, tous les petits cacas de l’espace ne se valent pas.
8 météorites sur 10 sont des chondrites.
Pour les puristes, c’est des péridotites avec du fer métal dedans.
C’est elles qui contiennent ces fameuses pépites de magma, les chondres.
Et ces chondrites sont les mamies de l’espace.
Elles se sont formées y’a 4,55 milliards d’années et depuis, elles n’ont pas bougé d’un iota.
Les vendeurs de crème anti-âge les détestent.
Voici une expérience amusante à faire chez vous.
Prenez la Terre tout entière et passez-la au mixeur,
vous obtiendrez la même chimie qu’une chondrite.
Les mêmes éléments dans les mêmes proportions.
Ce qu'en déduisent les scientifiques, c'est qu'à l'origine, la Terre était un tas de chondrites éparpillées.
Attirées par la gravité, elles se sont agglomérées les unes aux autres.
Puis à cause de l’énergie produite par les collisions et la radioactivité des éléments contenus dans les chondrites,
les roches ont chauffé chauffé...
Tant et si bien que le tas de chondrites a fondu pour devenir une boule de magma en apesanteur.
Les éléments les plus lourds de la soupe ont migré vers le centre sous l'effet de la gravité
alors que les autres sont restés en surface.
D'où la formation des couches concentriques de la Terre comme des pelures d'oignon.
le noyau riche en fer et en nickel, puis le manteau silicaté autour.
Pour pas que la planète n’attrape froid.
Et ce scénario, que je décris là pour la Terre, serait le même pour les autres planètes rocheuses du système solaire, comme Mars.
Et là où ça devient intéressant, c'est qu'on trouve aussi des météorites riches en fer et en nickel.
On les appelle des sidérites, et chimiquement,
elles ressemblent diablement au noyau terrestre en fait.
Celles-là, elles sont tellement belles !
Ces figures géométriques que vous voyez, c’est ce qu’on appelle des figures de Wittgenstein.
Des figures de William Shatner.
Monté pitié !
Widmanstätten.
D'autres météorites, qu'on appelle achondrites,
ressemblent à nos gabbros, nos basaltes, nos péridotites.
C'est un peu comme si ces météorites venaient d'un corps différencié comme la Terre
et que leurs débris auraient voleté joyeusement jusqu'à nous, dites donc !
En fait c'est exactement ça.
Si vous mixez ces météorites ensemble, vous obtiendrez à nouveau une chondrite.
Donc les chondrites qu’on échantillonne aujourd’hui sont les mamans de la Terre, de Mars, et en réalité de tous les corps “rocheux” du système solaire.
Puisqu'elles ont aussi la même chimie que le Soleil, si on omet tous ses gaz, parce qu’il en contient un paquet.
Il devrait essayer le charbon actif.
Les scientifiques pensent que ces mamies de l’univers se seraient formées lors de la condensation de la nébuleuse solaire
sous l’impulsion de décharges électriques,
quand le système solaire n’était encore qu’un gros mouton de poussière cosmique.
Et c’est justement parce que c’est les plus anciennes roches du système solaire,
que les chondrites sont de si bons témoins de notre histoire.
Pas seulement l’Histoire des Hommes, ni celle des sciences,
ni même celle de la Terre mais bien de tout le système solaire.
J’insiste, parce que c’est ouf quand même.
Et à ce titre, nous leur devons le respect même si elles ressemblent à rien.
Je veux dire, comparées aux sidérites, ou même aux pallasites.
C’est des météorites de fer avec des cristaux d’olivine incrustés,
elles correspondraient très précisément à la limite entre le noyau et le manteau d’un corps différencié.
Mais c'est pas fini.
Comme si c'était pas assez classe comme ça, les météorites détiennent peut-être aussi la clé de l’énigme de l’apparition de la vie sur Terre.
Parce que si jamais on arrive à trouver ne serait-ce que des petites bactéries à la con sur ces météorites,
ça pourrait confirmer l’hypothèse de la panspermie,
qui dit que la vie sur Terre aurait été apportée depuis l’espace.
A l’heure actuelle, on n’en a encore aucune preuve de ça.
Y a bien eu une fausse alerte à la fin des années 1990,
quand une équipe américaine a cru trouver des tout petits vers fossiles sur une météorite martienne.
L’annonce a d’ailleurs été faite par le Donald Trump de l’époque, Bill Clinton.
Mais en fait, c’était juste des artefacts analytiques. Ça la fout un peu mal pour les Américains.
Mais à défaut de trouver de la vie sur les météorites,
on y trouve parfois des briques de vie.
Des molécules complexes comme des acides aminés ou de l’urée.
Donc en ce sens, les météorites pourraient avoir apporté certains ingrédients nécessaires à la vie sur Terre.
Cela dit, on n’est pas beaucoup plus avancés, parce qu’on sait pas du tout comment passer de cette chimie prébiotique, à la vie.
Par contre, c’est bel et bien une météorite qui nous a fait découvrir une nouvelle forme de vie.
Des bactéries nanométriques, 1.000 fois plus petites que l’épaisseur d’un poil de barbe d’Un Créatif.
Elles ont été trouvées dans la météorite de Tataouine, tombée en Tunisie en 1931.
C’est une achondrite qui ressemble à nos péridotites ou nos gabbros.
Manque de bol, c’était une contamination terrestre, ces bactéries n’avaient rien d’alien en elles.
Elles ont dû partir à l'assaut du caillou quand il mijotait tranquillement sur Terre en attendant qu'on le découvre.
N’empêche qu’on savait pas, à l’époque, qu’il pouvait exister des bactéries aussi petites sur Terre. Et ça, c’est grâce à une météorite qu’on l’a découvert.
Et depuis qu’on sait qu’elles existent, on en a trouvé beaucoup d’autres ailleurs dans de « vieilles » météorites.
Et ça, diantre ! Que c’est beau.
Merci, et si vous aimez les petits cacas de l’espace, n’hésitez pas à liker cette vidéo,
à la partager, à vous abonner, à mettre la cloche
et à nous rejoindre sur le Discord pour parler de… Bill Clinton.
Ah bah c’était clairement une météorite. Venez voir, elle a pété la vitre carrément.
Non mais c’est pas plutôt toi qui vient de péter la vitre là ? Parce qu’on vient de l’entendre et tu as du verre partout.
Quoi ? Mais pas du tout, qu’est-ce que tu racontes ?
De toutes façons, on ne peut pas la garder, c’est pas moral.
Non mais attend, on vote. Moi je suis pour qu’on la garde, on va la garder.
Oui oui, moi aussi.
Bon bah voilà 2 voix sur 4.
Du coup, Valentine pourrait voter que ça changerait rien, et de toute façon elle risque d’être d’accord avec nous.
Donc bah, on la garde.
Yes !
Yes ! Yes ! Yes !
Et si vous avez plein de questions,
n'hésitez pas à venir me les poser en direct sur Touiche !
Parce que j'y serais là pendant que la vidéo sera diffusée.
Comme ça on va pouvoir débriefer tout ça ensemble.
Et puis regarder des jolies de photos de météorites et plein de trucs trop cool. Aller venez !
Ça va être bien.